yeah welcome to this video I'm d4f all
that's going on I'm a GM GM from the US
i don't think i played him before try
hand at the open sicilian with a six and
let's play conservatively a force it's a
good move actually it's not not bad at
all aha ip6 very hardly be six yeah
Bishop sometimes Bishop f3s is good I
try that maybe he's going ok 79 Bishop
d7 IV five the should should win
material so he needs to go look ASAP now
I think so Bishop b3 and a high versus a
possibility and this looks this looks
own weird what I just take here I don't
see the big idea okay just just winning
an exchange okay yeah like to be on
default but no way to accomplish that
need to return to cancel so um p + b2 I
can I can just play be three
so what is the 6.6 pawn so I'm just it's
in it's a complete hold exchange okay
this looks like a good one try to
exchange material and if he takes on d5
eat XD 5 night before that's a five
hanging of course you to also but i can
i can place your folks to f3 yeah i'm
not sure i want to allow him any of this
and I probably just retreat a tech
e-cigs know that a six so a six and A
five is hanging and I'd like to place
you form to keep the pawn structure um
intact yeah see for Bishop teeth or
something like that and okay education
simply taking the eight pounds so it's
good enough I didn't want him to take
and anything like takes the queen's eggs
and Brooks is TC 20 so this can easily
lead to an exchange of all the pants on
the Queen silent this makes it difficult
maybe 94 m okay but night before I can
go Bishop deform okay libel and weakness
he on on c3 there is not a moving so
where's this okay I didn't disconnect
her always slight fear um okay see no
reason not to take it and now just drop
back it's just a pawn yeah okay see
phone yeah it's an exchange at the pawn
so it really should be enough to to win
but then the pieces that he has are not
on black 420 cake it is not learnt to
badly placed but now he disconnected
yeah I'm not quite sure this is really
was a technical issue on just out of
frustration yeah well um of course hehe
needs to somehow react to this maybe he
can go work c7 but it's it looks exactly
I thought maybe Lucy seven here although
what what he did this is not working I
mean just just this one a five looks
like like it's in really bad shape I
mean taking just it's the same as
resigning but yeah what should you do
some some very very unattractive would
move yeah I know it looks it looks
really bad maybe you can go here
doesn't look too too promising but
something like this for example yeah
it's probably too early yeah this seems
playable I mean it's not too bad some
everything's protected yeah thanks for
watching